man's figure I have words for both
Democrats and Republicans tonight let's
start with the Democrats we as a party
have spent the last six months the
greatest minds of our party dwelling on
the question the unbelievably consuming
question of how to get Olympia Snowe to
vote for health care reform I want to
remind us all Olympia Snowe was not
elected president last year Olympia
Snowe has no veto power in the Senate
Olympia Snowe represents a state with
one half of one percent of america's
population what America wants is health
care reform america doesn't care if it
gets 51 votes in the senate or 60 votes
the center 83 votes in the senate in
fact america doesn't even care about
that it doesn't care about that at all
what America cares about is this there
are over 1 million Americans who go
broke every single year trying to pay
their health care bills America cares a
lot about that America cares about the
fact that there are 40 4780 Americans
who die every single year on account of
not having health care that's 122
everyday America sure cares a lot about
that America cares about the fact that
if you have a pre-existing condition
even if you have health insurance it's
not covered America cares about that a
lot America cares about the fact that
you can get all the health care you need
as long as you don't need any American
cares about that a lot but America does
not care about procedures processes
personalities America doesn't care about
that at all so we have to remember that
as Democrats we have to remember that's
what's at stake here is life and death
enormous amounts of money and people are
counting upon us to move ahead America
understands what's good for America
America cares about health care America
cares about jobs America cares about
education of that energy independence
America does not care about process or
politicians or personalities or anything
like that and I have a few words for my
Republican friends tonight as well I
guess I do have some Republican friends
let me say this
last week I held up this report here and
I pointed out that in America there's 40
4789 Americans who die every year
according to this Harvard report
published in a peer-reviewed journal
because they have no health insurance
that's an extra 400 789 Americans who
died whose lives could be saved and
their response was to ask me for an
apology to ask me for an apology that's
right to ask me for an apology well I'm
telling you this I will not apologize I
will not apologize I will not apologize
for a simple reason America doesn't care
about your feelings I violated no rules
by pulling this report to America's
attention I think a lot of people didn't
know about it beforehand but America
does care about health care in America
and if you're against it then get out of
the way just get out of the way you can
lead you can follow or you can get out
of the way and I'm telling you now to
get out of the way America understands
that there's one party in this country
that's in favor of health care reform
and one party that's against it and they
know why they understand that if Barack
Obama were somehow able to cure hunger
in the world the Republicans would blame
him for overpopulation they'd understand
that if Barack Obama could somehow bring
about world peace they blame him for
destroying the defense industry in fact
they understand that if Barack Obama has
a BLT sandwich tomorrow for lunch they
will try to ban bacon but that's not
what America wants America wants
solutions to its problems and that
begins with health care and that's what
I'm speaking for tonight I yield the
rest of my time the gentleman yields
back